le problème c'est que déjà je pense que
tout le monde le sait mais on en trouve
absolument partout dans Paris c'est que
je demande sur les dix dernières années
je pense qu'il y a pas une fête je suis
allé où il y a pas des gens qui
consommaient de la drogue il y en a
absolument et dans tous les milieux dans
tous les milieux bah surtout de la
surtout de la cocaïne pas tellement de
l'herbe mais surtout sur surtout en
grande partie de la cocaïne certaines
personnes prennent du GHB comme ça pas
du tout dans le fonctionnement d'abuser
des gens mais uniquement pour avoir des
effets des équipes nautiques mais ok
n'en trouve partout mais si vous en avez
pas on vous en propose donc c'est c'est
complètement dérange c'est que dès que
vous allez aux toilettes quelque part
qu'il y a toujours quelqu'un qui vous en
propose voilà parce que vous êtes connu
parce que vous avez une bonne tête ou
parce qu'il veut vous faire plaisir etc
donc on en trouve partout et pour s'en
sortir parce que moi je j'ai été arrêté
j'ai arrêté pour ça donc j'ai pas de
honte à en parler c'est à dire puisque
on en a jamais vraiment parlé mais
arrêté chez moi parce qu'il y avait
quelqu'un il suivait il suivait à dealer
qui se trouve je faisais une fête chez
moi le dealer sortait de chez moi et
j'ai eu pas le bol du coup c'est sur moi
que c'est tombé voilà enfin pas de bol
je le méritais certainement et je
reviendrai sur la jonction thérapeutique
et d'entre nous une foutaise totale
parce que du coup moi j'avais aussi au
moyen
de faire une agence de son thérapeutique
qui n'oblige pas du tout à faire des
contrôles c'est-à-dire que vous pouvez
continuer à en prendre tout en
remplissant le contrat que le juge vous
a donné c'est que vous voyez un
psychiatre qui essaie de savoir pourquoi
vous en prenez et pour évidemment
essayer de vous dire vous n'allez pas
besoin en fait arrêter d'en prendre mais
on vérifie pas si vous en prenez
toujours donc en fait c'est comme un
alcoolique qui a règne et une séance
bourrée à une séance de c'est j'entends
bien ce que vous dites mais c'est c'est
pas que c'est une photo et c'est qu'en
fait il y a un manque d'incohérence et
de congruence entre la partie du
psychiatre et la partie de la police
mais c'est pas aussi cadre de vous
contrôler en fait c'est pas le principe
de l'entreprise
et donc et le problème c'est que si on
veut s'en sortir on est obligé d'arrêter
de changer déjà de son cercle d'amis son
milieu de vie parce que tous les gens en
principe on s'entour de gens qui en
prennent et tous les gens qu'on côtoie
chez qui on sent etc ils en prennent ils
ont pas forcément dans la volonté de
vouloir arrêter donc il y a de grandes
chances qu'on vous en proposant la
soirée si vous avez décidé d'arrêter
c'est très dur de refuser quand vous en
propose si vous y avez déjà goûté
c'était les banques vous êtes
pratiquement obligé de vous mettre au
vert de plus sortir de ne plus voir les
anciens amis que vous voyez comme ça
pour changer complètement de d'univers
autrement vous êtes presque pension de
replonger pour vous donc c'est pour
Pierre Palma c'était impossible de s'en
sortir quand on aime la moi j'ai arrêté
complètement les fêtes etc je sais pas
peut-être que c'était pour ça il n'y a
pas non j'ai pas mis un patch mais j'ai
changé j'ai changé complètement de vie
j'ai changé de ville j'ai changé de vie
voilà puis je trouve que là je m'a aidé
beaucoup parce que j'ai trouvé ça
complètement ridicule de continuer à
aller en boîte passer 60 ans voilà donc
du coup ça m'a beaucoup aidé mais quand
on est jeune et qu'on y a goûté et qu'on
aime sortir il faut une vraie force ou
alors être aidé par des gens des proches
etc pour réussir à s'en sortir et si on
a toujours la fête comme Pierre pamade
c'est sûr que c'est et vous savez que
Pierre man détestait la campagne je
crois que le confirmer il détestait ça
il avait vraiment acheté cette maison là
dans cet objectif c'est de s'éloigner
des grandes villes et d'être dans un
endroit où on ne peut pas de trouver
dealer c'était l'objet que ça d'accord
ou on vous livre en un quart d'heure ça
va plus vite que le McDo
on se dit moi il y a plein de gens qui
m'ont dit il est sorti de chez lui pour
aller peut-être recharger pour aller
récupérer comment tu fais pour en
trouver comment ça se passe déjà on peut
suffit de poster des choses sur sur snap
ou comme ça il y a toujours des gens qui
vont qui proposent ils font carrément
des des flyers sur un sur un star ou sur
euh
tu te rends compte de ça bien sûr bien
sûr vous arrivez commandé une fois parce
que à Paul vous a donné un numéro après
il se il change de numéro et du coup
vous en avez moi je reçois encore plein
de propositions sur mon téléphone je
bloque à chaque fois je bloque les
numéros je le bloque mais ça ne s'arrête
jamais parce qu'il change de téléphone
tous les 15 jours donc j'ai bloqué le
numéro mais 15 jours après la nouveau
numéro il me renvoie des messages donc
je dis stop je j'envoie des stops je
bloque etc ça ne s'arrête jamais donc si
vous l'avez pas la force mentale vous
regardez votre téléphone vous en avez
j'ai dû recevoir 10 aujourd'hui
à protéger vos ados des réseaux sociaux
je ne pourrai jamais
protéger vos ados des réseaux sociaux ça
flingue tout chez eux bien sûr
scolarités